فيه صعوبه كبيره بوجهها الموظفين بانه
يحطوا خط فاصل ما بين العمل ووقت الفراغ
وخاصه مع التطور وسائل التواصل وامكانيه
الوصول للشخص وين مكان في اي زمان وفي اي
مكان وكثير من الموظفين بيتمنوا وقت
يطلعوا اجازه خلاص ينفصلوا عن العمل تماما
ويعيشوا اجازتهم بكل تفاصيلهالاحظاتها
بصراحه الامنيه او الحل صار عند الشركه
هنديه للرياضيات الخياليه اسمها دريم
سويرس فرضت غرامي قدرها 1200 دولار امريكي
في حاله تصل احد الموظفين بزميله اذا كان
في اجازه وقال مؤسس الشركه خارجين انه
للموظف انه يبتعدوين فاصل عن نظام الشركه
مره واحده في العام من دون رسائل ولا بريد
الكتروني ولا حتى مكالمات ولا شغل من
البيت ولا غيره وعلى فكره مشكله التواصل
مع الموظفين اللي بيكونوا في اجازاتهم
السنويه من قبل العملي مشكله رائعه مش
جديده وفي بعض الحكومات استخدامات في
السابق قانون الحق في قطع الاتصال مثل في
فرنسا في عام 2017 وغيرها كمان من الدول
مثل اسبانيا وايطاليا والبرتغال والمانيا
واسكتلندا طبقت قواعد مماثله بتجبر اصحاب
العمل على تحديد متى يمكن ان يكون الموظف
خالي او خاليين الموظفين من رسائل العمل
واحرار في اجازتهم تماما في وقت في في
كثير موظفين سعيدين ومرحبين بهذا النوع من
نوع من الاخبار لانه المفروض او يعني يحق
لهم انه ينفصلوا تماما عن العمل في وقت
الاجازه في ناس ثانيه بخصوصا من المختصين
في مجال الموارد البشريه شايفين انه
بصراحه موظفين هالايام صايرين دلوعين
مره بدهم اجازه للصحه العقليه ومره بدهم
بيشتغلوا من البيت ومره بدهم ايام عمل اقل
وما حدا يزعجهم بالاجازه وغيره طلباتهم
كثره كثير وكثار علق على خبرنا اليوم هذا
انه شو بصير يعني اذا زميلك يحتاجك في
سؤال وانت اجازتك المنويه خربت الدنيا
حتى نحكي اكثر عن هذا الموضوع معنا من
عمان الدكتوره رولا عواد
مختصه في الهندسه البشريه وموجهه شخصيه
ومهانيه اهلا فيك دكتور معانا امم دكتوره
يعني بدي اسالك بدايه السؤال اللي اوردته
قبل قليل هل واللي هنابع من التعليقات هل
فعلا موظفينا الايام صايرين دلوعين شويه
زياده عن اللزوم والواحد يعني بيعطيهم
شويه حقوق بصيروا يتهربوا باكثر
صدقا هلا ما بنقدر نحكم عليهم بشكل قطعي
انهم دلوعين ولكن حقهم يعني حق الموظف حق
الانسان خلينا نحكي قبل ما يكون موظف انه
ينعم باجازه ينعم ب ااا يعني راحه نفسيه
وعقليه له لا يقدر ينتج ويعطي اكثر كمان
من ما هو ارضي عم يعطي وبينتج بمكانه
بالعمل فالافضل طبعا انه يحق له الاولويه
الحق له انه يكون في عنده اجازات يكون في
عنده وقت لراحته النفسيه ووقت راحت
الجسديه فانا لا ارى في ذلك اي دلع صراحه
طيب لدرجه انه يتغرم الموظف اللي مثلا عم
بينفذ شغل زميله اللي طالع اجازه مثلا
يعني عنده سؤال همم يعني اجابته كثير مهمه
لسايره العمل هالقد يعني صعب انه يسالوا
سؤال يجاوبوا على طبعا وسائل التواصل
الحديث الان مش ضروري يزعجوا كثير بدها
غرامي 1200$
هلا لسؤال صغير لا ولكن هون يعني يقع
الموضوع على عاتق الموارد البشريه وعلى
عاتق الاداره انه بوضع يعني خطه
يسموها خطه واضحه انه مين الشخص البديل في
حال هاي الاجازه شو المهمات او ال- ال-
الاشياء اللي مطلوبه من هذا الموظف خلي
حدا بديل يقدر انه يقوم بمقامه هل اذا كان
الشيءك جدا مهم وما حدا بيقدر غيره يتصرف
هون في عندنا ضعف بيكون همم بهذا الموضوع
الموجود بالمؤسسه او الشركه وكمان هو بيقع
على عاطف الموظفين نفسهم فممكن احنا اذا
ممكن شخص موظف يعني يتمادى مش عم نحكي على
سؤال بسيط ممكن يتمادى همم انه كان الموظف
موجود على راس عمله يعني مش كانه في اجازه
يتعامل معه هون يحق له انه يتعاملوا معه
بطريقه انه يعطوه همم غرامه على همم
التصرف تبعه غير هيك كمان اذا الموظف نفسه
همم لازم يطلع هاي الاجازه يعني يفصل
تماما ما بين اا وظيفته ما بين حياته
الشخصيه خليه يقعد هالاسبوع يعني اذا عم
نحكي عن اسبوع احنا الاسبوع هذا لازم يكون
مرتب لو منظم لو مخطط له من ابل عشان يقدر
يعطيه هاي الوظائف والمهمات اللي موجوده
لا الاشخاص اللي موجودين معه
خلال الاجازه هاي حق له طيب
ذكرت الفصل ما بين العمل وما بين الحياه
الشخصيه همم كمان التوازن ما بين هذول
الثنتين بنضلنا نسمع يعني في الفتره
الاخيره ورق لايف فعلا انه لازم انه لازم
ما بينهم همم كثير يعني مش عارفه ازاي
احنا فاهمين ال- ال- المصطلح غلط ولكن كيف
نقدر نساوي ما بينهم او نعمل ما بينهم
بلنس اذا كان العمل هو جزء من الحياه
فاحنا هيك ممكن نقول مثلا همم
مش لايف
هو جزء من الحياه مش كل الحياه
الورك لايف بلانس او التوازن او يعني
خلينا نحكي نوازن ما بين حياتنا المهنيه
وحياتنا الشخصيه هو انه ما تاثر كافيه على
الثانيه يعني انه ما تتاثر حياتي الشخصيه
او حياتي العائليه بوظيفتي مثلا بتاخر
كثير بالعمل مثلا الضغوطات اللي بتصير
عندي بالعمل كل هذا راح ياثر على حياتي
العائليه وبالتالي راح تتاثر على عملي
وعلى نفسيتي وكل الامور كل السير كان تبعد
حياتك لذلك لازم يكون في همم يعني توازن
نعمل توازن مش فصل للفصل مش موجود الفصل
كان موجود في كتب الاداره سابقا واضحك هذا
الشيء من يعني خلينا نحكي من ال 2017 وبعد
ذلك صار انه هو ما في فصل ما بنقدر نفصل
ولكن الشيء اللي بنقدر عليه انه ما نخليه
كف تضغط على الاخرى ان كانت حياتي
العائليه على حياه المهنيه وفايبرسا العكس
المشكله المه تقع عليها نعم اتفضل هي
المشكله انه الكلام جميل يعني من الناحيه
النظريه ولكن التطبيق صعب خصوصا مع كثره
المنافسه في ايامنا الحاليه يعني في كل
المهن وكل المجالات وهذا بيخلينا مضطرين
همم في بعض الاحيان انه نركز اكثر على
العمل من الحياه هذه الشخصيه على كل حال
شكرا ج- جزيلا لك دكتوره رولا عواد بزادوغ
مختصه في الهندسه البشريه وموجه شخصيه
ومهنيه كانت من عمان